Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You're watching.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, big news
from Washington today
as President Biden
finally delivered a major update
on his administration's
COVID response.
Yeah, just like
most phone updates,
Biden kept hitting "ignore"
until he had no choice.
He was like, "Alright.
Let's just update.
Give me Kilimanjaro.
Whatever it's called."
That's right.
Biden announced the U.S.
will soon make
high-quality masks available
to all Americans.
And to be sure
that everyone wears them,
here are the new masks.
It's Spidey. Yeah.
Spidey. We'll all do that.
That's right.
We're all getting masks.
Last year, we got 1,200 bucks.
This year...
cloth and a rubber band.
Yeah, I'll take it.
The White House says N95 masks
are the most protective,
which is too bad because
I assumed the bedazzled ones
I bought on Etsy
were 100% COVID-proof.
I washed it a couple times.
Yeah, the N95 masks
should be helpful.
Unfortunately, out of habit,
whenever somebody says, "N95,"
Biden calls it out, "Bingo!"
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
That's the joke of the week.
-Come on.
-That's the joke of the week.
That's the one.
[ Chuckles ]
Well, this is interesting.
I read that researchers in
Finland created a nasal spray
that they say can protect you
from all COVID variants
for eight hours.
[ Scattered cheers ]
When asked about breathing
through your mouth,
the company was like, "Uhh...
we didn't think of that, yeah."
"Oh, you're one
of those people."
Well, this is big news.
Today, Buckingham Palace
announced that Queen Elizabeth
has stripped Prince Andrew of
all his royal affiliations.
[ Scattered cheers ]
That's right.
She stripped Prince Andrew,
making her far and away
the oldest woman
to ever strip Prince Andrew.
[ Audience ohhs ]
That might be the joke --
-Oh, that might be --
-That might be --
-That might be the joke.
-Joke of the week,
week, week, week!
-Go, go, go, go, go!
Go, joke!
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, finally,
a city in California
wants to use green lasers
to try and drive away
thousands of crows that have
become a public nuisance.
But the lasers will backfire
when thousands of crows
are replaced
by thousands of cats.
We have a great show!